right here in the lobby of Ramsey
solutions they're here David and Mindy
are with us hey guys how are ya hi
welcome well great where do you guys
live we live in Salt Lake City Utah
South Jordan Utah to the suburb of Salt
Lake yeah serious commute to Nashville
to do a debt-free scream we're glad to
be here I had to turn into a whole
family event didn't you that's right
very cool so how much dad of you guys
paid we did four hundred and eighteen
thousand dollars in three years and 11
months yeah okay
making what kind of money during that
time well it started at about a hundred
and thirty-six mm we're up to about a
170 or so now excellent what do you guys
do for a living I'm a programmer and I'm
a stay-at-home homeschooling mom very
cool are you doing really well
congratulations and I'm guessing this
involves a home is here does yeah did
you sell the home no no you literally
cash flowed four hundred thousand
dollars you you have lived on nothing
we have lived on nothing right from
being I mean nothing you did this in
basically four years that's like a
hundred grand a year and while making
136 to 170 I mean you you have lived on
nothing nothing
we're very gizelle intense yeah that's
pretty crazy so what's this house worth
when we're probably five fifty maybe six
mmm-hmm how's it feel to have a paid-for
house as young as you are amazing it's a
little surreal I still how old are you
guys I'm 43 44 and you have a paid-for
house we do your weird funny ones my
else says they're looking regulations
you guys wow what a journey thank you
what a journey now how many kids do you
all know we have six okay give me their
names and ages we have Kaden our oldest
son is 20 mm-hmm calissa's our only
daughter she's 18 and then we have our
four younger boys here with us in the
lobby there's Carson who is 15 mm-hmm
Carter who is 12 Coleman who is 10 and
Kyler who's 8 mm for you those of you
watching at home looking and deeply into
your radio those are all spelled with a
k
so why why okay what what's the deal it
just started out that way we named our
first two kids and then by the time we
got to our third we we just knew we
liked K names that's right a turn so we
just start making up names at that point
that's right okay very cool good well
that's neat very fun so tell me about
your journey what happened to cause this
extreme intensity because you guys have
been on this man yeah I mean what
happened three years and eleven months
ago
well we actually owned a restaurant kind
of a site business but it was
all-consuming and when that restaurant
closed it was pretty devastating and
shortly thereafter we went on a family
reunion and on the way home from the
read family reunion it was January 1st
of 2012 and we just were talking to each
other at 32 hours to drive similar to
today we'll be driving home to him but
we literally couldn't stand this debt
and we had to come up with a solution
but when we started to break it down and
see what we could actually do we thought
well if we paid it off at ten years it
would be 40 thousand a year which just
seemed ridiculous so he said well maybe
15 and that was even just sounds so
depressing just because of the quantity
of years so we said what if what if we
did an eight well it's only $50,000 more
and then we said well I said to her do
many if what if we did in five and she's
like well that'd be like $80,000 a year
well we because of the closing of the
restaurant we were able to get a big tax
return the first year which really
jump-started us and we were able to
actually pay a hundred and eighteen
thousand dollars off the first year Wow
and the with that we also were able to
pay off the restaurant debt for the very
young on the day that we closed one year
later after the second year we really
were like well there's no way we're
gonna be able to do that again but we
did we just we saved
she was the saver I'm the maker and
after the third year it was quite easy
actually to get to the point where we
could pay that last hundred thousand
dollars off this year so we celebrated
on Black Friday while everybody was out
buying things that's the day that we
actually paid it off
27 I love it yeah that's fun so at what
point did you intersect with our stuff
in this journey that's a good question
yeah so I had just come across in the
library probably 10 years ago or
something the Total Money Makeover book
and just my dad's a financial planner I
love reading money books and so I just
picked it up and read it and got a
little fired up but he wasn't really
into it and so he's like it's fine if
you do it you know so I was working
through the baby steps myself and I got
it but I didn't get it and so but it
kind of took that and so I just kind of
was continuing doing it and even when we
did the restaurant I told him you can't
touch my rainy day fund by 6 months
expenses you know and so but finally
when we kind of hit that rock bottom I
think it was when he just you know had
that humility of feeling like oh what
are we gonna do and so then I got him
told him money makeover on CD he'd
listened to on his commute and then it
just kind of all found the place and
then when we had a road trip we started
talking okay so you'd listen to the CDs
before you went on the road trip okay
all right very cool very cool so that
gave you a framework to discuss it
anyway and and you had him trapped in
the car for hours can't get away that
lot of stuff happens on road trips it
does so some other good MO some of it
not but yeah that's good well
congratulations you guys it's got to
feel you have to feel not only like you
have you know that you've your
discipline and your intensity is
incredible so you not only have to feel
very proud and a sense of square
shoulders about that but then also now
just come the other side of that it's
almost like those how that coin when it
turns over is just this release there
has to be that there's an amazing amount
of freedom that's indescribable I mean
really to family and friends the amount
of freedom that we do have yeah just as
a mantel lifted off and and to his
credit he's so driven and once he got it
yeah ghazal and his game oh yeah so
driven and he just you know worked like
a maniac truly I think she was probably
the inspiration all the way through
through through the saving side of
things
you should tell your story welljust I
just make it a game a little bit you
know I thought we're doing rice and
beans and beans and rice then we're
gonna have fun do you want to end we
kind of get a kick out of beating the
system a little bit and so not only do
we you do with groceries couponing and
price matching but we did you know
figured out how to get things for free
and we cancelled our cable and got to
judge Montana and we just you know did
all these things that even you know we
have kids that are going to birthday
parties get invited and so we buy toys
on clearance and stockpile them and just
everything we could do and then we
figured out all these different things
mystery shop being a different things so
we could get oil changes for free go
down through his employer free swimming
lessons free Jimmer membership and it
just got to be a fun game like that and
and even some hotel stays as a secret
shopper I got to do that and so last
year for anniversary in March we just
went on a little road trip and I figured
out we had three free nights of hotels
we had some meals we drove only about an
hour away from our house and when he
took off work the people gave him a
really bad time his employee or his you
know fellow employees that he was going
to this little one-horse town for his
anniversary trip but less than a hundred
dollars for a whole three-day weekend
and you know I don't even know secret
shopping was still going on Sharon and I
did that for restaurants when we were
coming out of going broke it's the only
way we could afford to go out to eat and
they would say they would let us have
let us eat free and then we had to fill
out a little reports all it was yeah but
we got to eat for free yeah the
paperwork is thick she has to do all the
paperwork that goes with it is more than
fun because it's my time and and we save
the money yeah it's part of the game no
that's pretty cool
Wow good job you guys alright is the
whole family gonna join the screen get
in there guys jump in there you drive 32
hours you get to do your debt-free
screen that's how that's worked
unbelievable alright David and Mindy and
Carson and Carter and Coleman and Kyler
and four hundred and eighteen thousand
dollars paid off in 11 months making 136
two hundred and seventy and also playing
the game count it down let's hear a debt
free scream three two one word
well done you guys well done
man that's fun what a family Wow big
family they did it - they didn't while
being a big family now he's making good
money but man they lived on nothing to
do that in four in three years in 11
months that's amazing
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show I want
to write a song I want to own my own
business I want to make more money
those aren't goals those are wishes my
new year's resolution is to make more
money this year to wish